It's all about asking the right questions.
But it can unleash numerous opportunities for testing biological hypotheses.
If our predictions match our observations,
great! -- we got it right, so we can make further predictions
by changing this or that aspect of the model.
If, however, our predictions do not match our observations,
that means that some of our assumptions are wrong,
and so our understanding of the key mechanisms
of underlying biology
is still incomplete.
Luckily, since this is a model,
we control all the assumptions.
So we can go through them, one by one,
identifying which one or ones are causing the discrepancy.
And then we can fill this newly identified gap in knowledge
using both experimental and theoretical approaches.
Of course, any ecosystem is extremely complex,
and trying to describe all the moving parts is not only very difficult,
but also not very informative.
There's also the issue of timescales,
because some processes take place on a scale of seconds, some minutes,
some days, months and years.
It may not always be possible to separate those out experimentally.
And some things happen so quickly or so slowly
that you may physically never be able to measure them.
But as mathematicians,
we have the power to zoom in on any subsystem in any timescale
and simulate effects of interventions
that take place in any timescale.
Of course, this isn't the work of a modeler alone.
It has to happen in close collaboration with biologists.
And it does demand some capacity of translation
on both sides.
But starting with a theoretical formulation of a problem
can unleash numerous opportunities for testing hypotheses
and simulating scenarios and therapeutic interventions,
all in a completely safe way.
It can identify gaps in knowledge and logical inconsistencies
and can help guide us as to where we should keep looking
and where there may be a dead end.
In other words:
mathematical modeling can help us answer questions
that directly affect people's health --
that affect each person's health, actually --
because mathematical modeling will be key
to propelling personalized medicine.
And it all comes down to asking the right question
and translating it to the right equation ...
and back.
Thank you.
(Applause)